يبدو ان قدر قريه اغران يرتبط بالجرافات
بعد مرور سنه على وفاه الطفل ريان حبيسا
في جب عميق تتحرك مجددا لكن هذه المره
لتوسعه الطريق نحو القريه
طريق جبلي ووعر سلكه قبل عام الالاف من كل
المناطق بعد ان ملا اسم ريان الدنيا وشغل
الناس في موجه تضامن انسانيه غير مسبوقه
حزينه انتهت القصه ليتوارى بعدها اسم
اغران عن المشهد
ردمت الحفره ولم يبقى من الفاجعه الاليمه
سوى انابيب اسمنتيه وحديديه
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله
دعم لشبكه الكهرباء فالقريه تعاني
انقطاعها المتكرر وبنيت حضانه للاطفال
لكنها لا تزال مغلقه اما الصبيه فيلهون
وقد افتقدوا رفيقهم ريان
واقع القريه لا يسر فاعلين جمعويين والراي
عندهم ان المنطقه لم تستفد من الزخم
الاعلامي الذي واكب الفجعه ارى بعد مرور
سنه ان المنطقه لم يتغير بها شيء
لا زالت على حالها تعاني الويلات من كل
القطاعات ولم يتغير شيء ما عدا بعض
الاصلاحات الطفيفه لا تسمن ولا تغني اذا
كان هذا هو واقع قريه ايران وسكانها بعد
مرور عام على الفاجعه فكيف تبدو احوال
اسره الطفل ريان التي اختارت الاستقرار
بعيدا
قطعنا 100 كيلومتر لنصل الى تطوان في شقه
متواضعه استقرت الاسره اب عاطل من العمل
وافق غير منظور لا جديد في حياتها سوى
مولود ذكر رزقته في الذكرى الاولى لوفاه
ريان
من رحمه سيدي ربي كبير
[موسيقى]
ولادته ساجد رسامه للفرحه على وجوه
الوالدين المكلومين وشكلت ما قد يكون
نهايه ساره لقصه حزينه المختار
تطوان شماليه المغرب